la chaîne cherche à un présentateur qui
garde le ton très additionnel
c'est à dire hard agressif pas de langue
de bois et donc on cherche quelqu'un qui
est il soit dans cette lignée un petit
peu tu te sens capable de deux cas ça
serait ok je te présente béatrice alors
on va simuler une interview tu sais car
ils sont souvent 440 cheryl dans lequel
battre et c'est la gentillesse de se
prêter au jeu la paire karen cheryl tu
l'interview on fait des interviews
question hard ou là tu la déstabilise
est ensuite question qu oulaté faut
vraiment eu lie à fond sans jeu de mots
on y va le retour à la chanson s'est
passé comme on sait très bien je suis là
très bien et ça marche comment les
ventes de l'album ça commence à démarrer
ça démarre pas frissonnant top 50
non mais attends j'ai bien commencé à
vis de temps on a refait détends toi
parce que là tu es un petit peu crispé
alors détends toi ok ok on prend tout on
y va on prend tout le pays vivant oui
enfin et puis c'est pas agressif il faut
attaquer direct plus direct alors qu'à
rennes clitoridienne ou vaginale
il faut poser la question aux cantons
sauf choisi n'ai pas peur je sais ça
fait partie bonsoir car l on veut sortir
et oui alors depuis en gros je voudrais
1980 en début mais je sors un disque tu
sors un disque un bon disque de matière
et j'en ai dit encore une merde ouais tu
vois mon reconnaissent plus on la refait
bonsoir karel bos a retiré oui alors au
jour d'aujourd'hui tant d où la gc
risques tu sors une merde non c'est pas
une 25 rimbaud nice et on n'a pas fini
comme ça de nous aligner mer d'après mr
depuis
ça pollue quoi tu m'as d'anciennes
variétés pour gagner en danger voire
même temps que l'atmosphère dans une
variété voilà c'est dès aujourd'hui a
cédé aujourd'hui entre karachi
qu'est-ce qui chantent l'économie est ce
que vous vous êtes déjà balader tout nu
dans un champ de coquelicots
tu touches à l'arrivée c'est avec ce
genre de questions on voit clairement
que de drogue portant non pas du tout
sauf de la tête je veux qu'elle sévit
dans maintenant tu vas nous expliquer
pourquoi à ton avis la mission sera
mieux animé par toi que partir la
picardie sont parce que d'abord d'une
partie réalisant au moins certain qu'on
excuse toi mais peut-être si elles s'y
sont c'est un pote
ok d'accord la ccld pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de finale andy tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux